[Music]
hundreds of new corona cases in German
slaughterhouses
that's what mass tests in the meat
industry have revealed some meat
processing companies have been forced to
shut down temporarily the outbreak has
shed light on the dire working and
living conditions of employees critics
say it is these conditions that made it
easy for the virus to spread so rapidly
asleep again yeah alright splasher enjoy
stupid even then the shrine of iron the
German meat company best flesh is among
those that were shut down because of a
corona virus outbreak among employees
more than 200 have tested positive
worker's unions say crowded
accommodations are to blame for the
outbreak vest flesh has disputed the
claims saying that most of its employees
say in individual apartments of not more
than five people many workers are forum
and come from countries including Poland
Romania and Bulgaria in many cases they
are not directly employed by the meat
company but by subcontractors and these
subcontractors often cram them into tiny
shared accommodations they also
transport them in small crowded buses
all this makes it difficult for the work
has to follow the required hygiene
measures like keeping a distance and
avoiding contact quarantining those who
have tested positive is nearly
impossible the migrant workers often
have no means to fight this kind of
oppression this chapter school feuless
is so not miss Prague they fight to be
scarred in a jewish da wu coastal the
edema fights with kite loiter was
announced edinburgh in this telugu
todavía they don't have any copy area
but suppose it dropped about da by BMG
by dialing hi guys most with your farm
Oscar notes it's fun topic by Milan on
party rockers on dead for years
rights groups workers unions and
purrs of the German opposition have
demanded that working conditions in the
German meat industry change the recent
coronavirus outbreak has put the issue
back on the agenda such outbreaks are
not unique to Germany with meat
processing and packaging facilities
particularly hard-hit in the United
States some 22 facilities were shut down
due to rising kovat 19 cases among their
workers many of whom have recently
immigrated to the US or are undocumented
migrants in the US state of Maryland a
majority of the workforce in the poultry
industry is from the Haitian community
many have been affected by the corona
virus harder for them to cough say well
I'm gonna stay home without the approval
of their company and they will just
symptom they have to actually go to work
in April the US Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention released the
report that found that nearly 5,000 meat
packaging plant workers from nineteen
states had contracted the corona virus
and that social distancing measures were
particularly hard to implement at the
plant in spite of all that President
Trump recently signed an executive order
declaring meat processing plants
critical infrastructure that means they
have to remain open to ensure a constant
meat supply I think our biggest fear
right now is that we can't get the PPE
that we need and we can't get the test
in not because it's not available it's
because there's too much bureaucracy in
the way again
maybe's workers frontline employees in
this pandemic give them the access to
the PPE to the testing all the things
that they need to do their job safely
that's my biggest concern this is just
one example
of how around the world low-income
workers and minorities are at a higher
risk of contracting the virus in the
u.s. initial analysis of the coronavirus
cases has revealed a disturbing trend
members of the Latino and African
American community are more likely to
contract the corona virus than white
Americans New York Governor Andrew Cuomo
believes that a number of factors may
have contributed to this difference in
his state
there were existing health disparities
they were existing comorbidities
underlying illnesses diabetes etc I also
believe you have a greater percentage of
the quote unquote essential workers who
are African American Latino and while
everyone else or many other people had
the opportunity to lock down at home as
terrible as that was the essential
workers had to get up every morning and
go out and drive the bus and drive the
train and deliver the food Latinos and
African Americans have also reportedly
been hardest hit by the financial impact
of the corona crisis jobless rates in
the US are highest among these two
groups Latinos and non college graduates
are heavily concentrated in low-wage
occupations some worked in the leisure
and hospitality sectors in hotels
restaurants and bars where job cuts have
been especially brutal low income
workers across the world are facing
similar hardships two million
Indonesians have been laid off because
of the pandemic Budi Santos an is one of
them he can no longer work at a
restaurant or as a taxi driver the only
thing left for him is to do occasional
food delivery jobs but these earned him
much less dear my dear mr. Katanga Mac
Anita and Monica turn on you an
emergency call get one I mean packet I
do
vigilante Tonya rescue narrative
alternately monogatari yeah yeah Robin
commit to you
and according to the International Labor
Organization 55% of the world's
population are not covered by social
insurance or social assistance that's
about four billion people right now
thousands of migrant workers are on the
move
job losses have forced them to take on
long journeys back home often in large
groups the International Organization
for Migration is sounding alarm our
concern in Latin America is above all
the thousands of Venezuelans that have
lost their jobs in countries like
Ecuador and Colombia and are returning
back to Venezuela in large crowds
without any else screening and being
quarantined when they go back to to
Venezuela it's a similar picture in
India millions of low-income workers had
moved to big cities like Mumbai and New
Delhi to find work because of an imposed
lockdown they are now making the long
and often crowded journeys back to their
home villages and unemployment is not
the only thing making them flee from the
cities Mumbai and Delhi have become
dangerous coronavirus hotspots
transportation to the villages is still
limited the migrant work has often have
to travel in crowded buses or even on
foot a lack of protective gear and
sanitary facilities along the way make
it easier for them to catch the
coronavirus Sam died because of a lack
of food in fact the corolla crisis may
lead to a countrywide food shortage in
India this will very likely mainly
affect poorer communities this promise
is Peconic america this bookable
emerging economies are wounded
this media data Lochbaum merriman a dose
at Arby's the Ovadia scope Punky's
absolutely Orion 15 EB sabzi
automatically syndrome it's called a
smear Banco Milne para the International
Labour Organization is proposing a
number of measures to help those in
vulnerable working conditions
they include extending sickness benefits
to all workers even those in the
informal sector and migrants the company
of nineteen crisis is showing us that we
are only as secure as the most
vulnerable amongst us and this is why
it's so important that people have
access to high quality health care and
enough income security in order to be
able to eat and survive and this is why
universal social protection is so
important for recovery from the crisis
and for social justice back in Germany
the corona outbreak in meatpacking
facilities has led to an introduction of
new restrictions for the industry from
January 2021 meat industry workers can
only be employed directly by a company
not by subcontractors furthermore
employers that provide a foundation will
be responsible for informing authorities
about where their migrant workers are
live
fines for violating working hour
restrictions have also been doubled